connu pour ses fjords et ses paysages
nordiques depuis un an la Norvège attire
surtout la tension pour ses ressources
énergétiques
dans cette usine de Stavanger ont
construit des outils utilisés notamment
dans le forage du pétrole et du gaz
après des années très tranquille la
production a repris à un rythme effréné
[Musique]
oui
explique même le directeur général son
but se préparer à répondre aux besoins
des nouveaux projets pétroliers et
gaziers en train d'être développés
l'impact de cette production se sent
dans toute cette région d'où partent les
pièces utilisées pour l'éolien le gazier
et le pétrolier en haute mer sans gaz
russe l'appétit des Européens pour
l’énergie norvégienne agrandement
augmenté depuis le début de la guerre
très élevés du gaz depuis un an cette
économiste explique que le PIB de la
Norvège a augmenté de 30% l'an dernier
le pays a fait des profits records liés
aux recettes énergétiques et ce n'est
pas terminé
pour l'année 2023 le gouvernement
norvégien s'attend même à ce que les
profits liés à l'exploitation pétrolière
et gazières atteignent un montant
équivalent à plus de 175 milliards de
dollars canadiens une somme énorme qui
soulève des débats importants sur la
manière dont elle devrait être utilisée
chaque soir devant le Parlement à Oslo
c'est manifestants réclament des appuis
financiers et militaires pour l'Ukraine
nous avons les moyens nous devons aider
beaucoup d'argent avec la guerre
ajoute-t-il le Parlement récemment
approuvé une enveloppe d'aide à Kiev
équivalent à 9 milliards de dollars
canadiens sur cinq ans
Oslo se défendent profiter même
indirectement du conflit Stone
responsabilités comme celle de répondre
aux besoins énergétiques de pays
européens comme l'Allemagne dont la
Norvège est devenue le principal
fournisseur de gaz concours de la
dernière année
sécurité la production gazière de
Norvège a donc bondi de 8% en un an
malgré cette hausse des activités les
autorités assurent que leurs objectifs
en matière de transition énergétique
demeure inchangés mais certains
craignent que la guerre et ses impacts
bousculent ces priorités que ce soit
l'hydrogène l'énergie éolienne des
profits sont beaucoup moins les salaires
seront moi nous aimerons changer nos
activités industrielles mais
on veut pas laisser
cette revenue colossale on continue à
gagner
l'entrepreneur svène Christian Sun admet
avec la demande actuelle l'importance de
la transition est moins au cœur des
conversations
le virage sera inévitable dans son usine
alimentée au biogaz et à
l'hydroélectricité ont fourni aussi des
pièces pour l'industrie éolienne dans
l'immédiat ce sont tout de même les
besoins en énergie fossile qui s'impose
même dans le calme norvégien difficile
d'ignorer les bouleversements qui
secouent le marché énergétique européen